paintball sold for one and a half
billion dollars his net was 180. he put
money in three different companies which
of those three companies you think he
put the most money in that's what I
thought as well but he put 100 million
in SpaceX he's been wanting to go to
space since he was a kid when you do
what you do because it's the Love of the
Game you can't stop musk is playing a
game he's not in business people don't
realize this the thing that Elon has
that other entrepreneurs and his
competitors don't have is that in his
mind he's saving humanity and so when we
talk about having a big vision for the
future I can't think of one that's
bigger than save the world I think in
his heart he genuinely believes that and
I think maybe more importantly the heart
of all the people that he has in his
companies they work that much harder
they try and solve problems that are
hard even though they don't have to
because they all are on a mission to
save the world and that's a very
powerful force